Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Zachary was still shaking his head. Welcome to Thailand. Now let me school you. What you and Sarai could do and get away with in Boulder can't be done here in Phuket. Not if she's going to save face and honor her father. She's a good girl. And here in Thailand, good girls don't fool around with
感谢您收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验以及加入我们备受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。扎卡里仍然在摇头。欢迎来到泰国。现在让我来教教你。你在博尔德可以做且能蒙混过关的事，在这里普吉岛可不行。除非她打算保全颜面并维护她父亲的名誉。她是个好女孩。而在泰国，好女孩是不会跟
or get involved with farangs. What the hell is a farang? It's the Thai word for Europeans, or non-Thai men. It's mostly used to describe white guys. Since we're black, you and I are actually Ferang Dam." Alexander stared at his twin for a moment. Well, damn! he said, suddenly laughing. Laughing with him, Zachary shrugged. Ferang is also the word for guava fruit. Go figure! So that, Dominic, was Guilty Pleasures by Deborah Mello. I'm sure you'll have read it. It's a romance novel describing the rivalry between two American brothers,
或者与法朗鬼扯上关系的。法朗到底是个什么鬼东西？这是泰国人对欧洲人或非泰国男人的称呼。它主要用来形容白人。既然我们是黑人，你和我其实都是“黑法朗”。亚历山大盯着他的双胞胎兄弟看了一会儿。去你的！他突然大笑着说道。扎卡里陪着他笑，耸了耸肩膀。法朗也是番石榴水果的词。真没想到！所以，多米尼克，那是由黛博拉·梅洛所著的《罪恶的快感》。我相信你一定读过。这是一部浪漫小说，描述了两个美国兄弟之间的竞争，
both of them black as we heard, Alexander and Zachary, the Hammer Barrett. And they're both absolute fitness fanatics like me. And they're both obsessed by the beautiful Sarai Montrey, who is a personal trainer and the former Miss Thailand. So of all the introductory readings we've ever had on the rest of history, that's probably the weirdest. What's going on? Well, I'm sure what will have stuck out for you was the use of this phrase, Farang Dam, which literally means black Franks. And it was first used in the 60s to describe black American servicemen who were being stationed in Thailand during the Vietnam
正如我们所听到的，他们两个都是黑人，亚历山大和扎卡里，“重锤”巴雷特。而且他们两个都像我一样是不折不扣的健身狂热分子。他们两个都迷恋着美丽的萨赖·蒙特雷，她是一名私人教练兼前泰国小姐。所以，在我们《历史其余部分》所有的开场导读中，这大概是最诡异的一段了。这到底是怎么回事？嗯，我确信最让你印象深刻的一定是这个词组的使用，“Farang Dam”，字面意思是“黑色的法朗”。这个词最早出现在20世纪60年代，用来形容在越南期间驻扎在泰国的美国黑人军人
War. And Thai is just one of a number of Asian languages that uses variation of this word Frank to describe Europeans and Americans. So the Turks for example they use the word Franks to mean foreigners or Westerners, outsiders, don't they? And lots of people do that. Yeah, so the Greeks used to, the Arabs still do. It's a word that's used in Urdu, in Hindi, in Chinese, in Malay. And you'll have noticed in that passage of Immortal Prose I just read the use of the word Farang to describe guava fruit and the reason for that is because
战争。泰语只是众多使用这个词（即“法朗”的变体）来形容欧洲人和美国人的亚洲语言之一。比如土耳其人，他们用“法朗”一词来指代外国人、西方人或局外人，对吧？很多人都这样做。是的，希腊人曾经这样做过，阿拉伯人现在还在这样做。这个词在乌尔都语、印地语、汉语、马来语中都有使用。你刚才在我朗读的那段不朽散文中会注意到，“Farang”一词被用来形容番石榴果实，原因在于
it was introduced to Thailand by the Portuguese in the 16th century. So it's basically a kind of a Frankish fruit. And similarly in Cambodia, I gather a turkey is a Frankish chicken. So essentially anything that comes from what today we might call the West is Frankish. And it's absolutely bizarre, because the Franks are a people who, you know, they take us back over a millennium and a half, back to an incredibly distant age and an incredibly distant part of the world. And the Franks today and for the next few weeks are going to be our great theme and it is an amazing, amazing story. Well, the story of The Franks is the story in history I think that's most reminiscent of the sort of fantasy novels of Tolkien and George R. R. Martin and whatnot. So it's a world
它是在16世纪由葡萄牙人引入泰国的。所以它基本上算是一种法兰克水果。同样在柬埔寨，我听说火鸡就是法兰克鸡。因此，基本上所有源自我们今天可能称之为西方的事物都是法兰克的。这绝对是匪夷所思的，因为法兰克人这个民族，你知道的，他们的历史可以追溯到一个半世纪以前，追溯到一个极其遥远的时代和世界极其遥远的角落。而法兰克人在今天以及接下来的几周里，将成为我们宏大的主题，这是一个极其惊人的故事。嗯，法兰克人的故事在我看来是历史上最让人联想到托尔金、乔治·R·R·马丁等人的那种奇幻小说的故事。所以这是一个
of crumbling empires, of landscapes kind of scarred with ruins of sorcerers and magic and men with massive axes and warrior queens and people plotting to poison each other and dragons and kind of mountain battles and citadels and it really has got it all hasn't it? The other comparison to fantasy novels is that everybody pretty much in the story has completely mad names. Right. Gunderbad. It's a good name. Wolfegund, I think my favourite
帝国崩塌的世界，风景里满是术士和魔法的废墟残迹，有挥舞着巨斧的战士女王、密谋互相毒害的人们、巨龙、山地战以及城堡，它真的是应有尽有，对吧？它与奇幻小说的另一个相似之处在于，故事里的每个人几乎都有着极其疯狂的名字。没错。冈德巴德。这是个好名字。沃尔费冈德，我想我最喜欢的
chimney child, a girl's name. So anyone out there looking for a name for a daughter, I think that's a brilliant name. But it is also a hugely significant period historically, because basically it's about how one age passes away, another is incubated. And you could say it's the great hinge moment in European history because it's the story of the collapse of the Roman Empire in the West and the emergence of what will become medieval civilization. So at the beginning we are in Gaul and by the end of it we are in France and of course France it is the land of the Franks, Frankia, that's where the word France comes from.
“烟囱之子”，这是一个女孩的名字。所以外面的任何人如果在给女儿找名字的话，我觉得这是一个绝妙的名字。但它在历史上也是一个极其重要的时期，因为这基本上讲述了一个时代的消逝与另一个时代的孕育。可以说它是欧洲历史上的伟大转折点，因为它是西罗马帝国崩溃以及日后中世纪文明崛起的故事。所以在开头我们身处高卢，而到结尾我们身处法兰克，当然法兰克就是法兰克人的土地，法兰克尼亚，这就是“法国”一词的由来。
Let's kick off at the beginning. So we are in the Roman Empire in the 4th France, it is the land of the Franks, Frankia, that's where the word France comes from. Let's kick off at the beginning. So we are in the Roman Empire in the fourth century AD, the middle of the fourth century, and Gaul is still part of the empire, but it's coming under increasing pressure, isn't it, on the frontiers from the movement of all kinds of Germanic peoples. And that's where this story begins. Yeah, so let's look at a particular moment. It's the winter of AD 357 going into 358. We are in the aftermath of Constantine, the great emperor who has reunited the empire after it had been kind of divided up. And in Constantinople we have Constantine's son, Constantius II, and he has sent his cousin, a man called Julian,
让我们从头开始。所以我们身处公元4世纪的罗马帝国……法兰克就是法兰克人的土地，法兰克尼亚，这就是“法国”一词的由来。让我们从头开始。所以我们身处公元4世纪中期的罗马帝国，高卢仍然是帝国的一部分，但它在边境上面临着来自各种日耳曼民族迁徙的日益巨大的压力，不是吗？故事就是从这里开始的。是的，让我们来看看一个特定的时刻。那是公元357年到358年的冬天。我们正处于君士坦丁大帝统治之后的余波中，这位伟大的皇帝在帝国分裂后将其重新统一。在君士坦丁堡，我们有君士坦丁的儿子，第二代君士坦提乌斯，他派了他的堂弟，一个名叫尤利安的人
to stabilize the Rhine frontier, the frontier of Gaul. And the most menacing enemy that Julian faces is a great confederation of peoples called the Alemanni. And in the summer of 357, he has met with them outside Strasbourg in a great battle. Julian and his forces have been massively outnumbered. But as the Romans so often do, he has won a crushing victory over the barbarians. The king of the Alemanni has been captured, has been sent off to Constantius in Constantinople and it's all looking good. However, to the north of Strasbourg, so higher up the Rhine, another group of barbarians
去稳定莱茵河边境，即高卢的边境。尤利安面临的最具威胁性的敌人是一个名为阿勒曼尼人的庞大部族联盟。在公元357年的夏天，他在斯特拉斯堡郊外的一场大战中遇到了他们。尤利安和他的部队在人数上处于绝对劣势。但正如罗马人经常做的那样，他对蛮族取得了压倒性的胜利。阿勒曼尼人的国王被俘虏，并被送往君士坦丁堡的君士坦提乌斯那里，一切看起来都很好。然而，在斯特拉斯堡以北，也就是莱茵河上游，另一群蛮族
have been taking advantage of Julian's distraction to pillage the line of the Meuse Valley. So that's through what's now Belgium. And these Dominic are the Franks. So this is their first appearance, right, in the sources as the named group. From this moment they're called the Franks, are they? So the Franks have been a kind of a constant on the Roman frontier since the third century. We'll look at exactly where they come from in a minute. Okay. But just for now this is a kind of particular instant which illustrates the Roman reactions to them and the kind of the relationship between these two people, the Roman superpower and this kind of, essentially
趁着尤利安分心之机，大肆劫掠了默兹河谷一带。也就是现在的比利时境内。多米尼克，这些就是法兰克人。所以这是他们作为被点名的群体首次在史料中亮相。从这一刻起他们就被称为法兰克人了，对吗？因此，自3世纪以来，法兰克人一直是罗马边境上的一种常客。我们一会儿再详细看看他们到底从哪里来。好的。但就目前而言，这是一个特定的历史瞬间，它说明了罗马人对他们的反应，以及这两个民族之间的关系，即罗马超级大国与这样一个基本上
at this point, they're just an annoyance on the flank of the great Roman monster, the Beomoth. And these Franks, there are only about 600 of them. They've taken possession of a couple of abandoned fortresses on the line of the Myrs and Julian wants to nail them down. He doesn't want them to kind of cause trouble. So he lays them under siege, even though it's beyond the campaigning seasons, the snows are coming down. And in fact, as the winter comes on and there's the risk of the river freezing over, we know from a historian called Ammianus Marcellinus, who's a great fan of Julian, great historian
在这个阶段，他们只是伟大罗马庞然大物（贝希摩斯）侧翼的一个麻烦制造者。这些法兰克人只有大约600人。他们占领了默兹河沿岸的一两座废弃堡垒，尤利安想要把他们彻底清除。他不想让他们制造麻烦。因此，尽管已经过了作战季节，大雪纷飞，他还是对他们实施了围攻。事实上，随着冬天的临近，河面结冰的风险也随之增加，我们从历史学家阿米安纳斯·马尔切利努斯（Ammianus Marcellinus）那里得知，他是尤利安的超级粉丝，也是这一时期伟大的历史学家
of this period. And he writes, anxious in case the savages should take advantage of some moonless night across the frozen river. Julian gave orders that all night from sunset to dawn soldiers should row up and downstream in scouting vessels, thereby breaking up the ice and denying the barbarians the chance to escape. And this is very effective. Finally the Franks have no choice to surrender and you might think that Julian would then put them to the sword but he doesn't. He settles them on
他写道：“为了担心野蛮人在某个无月的夜晚利用结冰的河面渡河，尤利安下令，整夜从日落到黎明，士兵们都要乘侦察船在上下游划行，以此打破冰层，剥夺蛮族逃跑的机会。”这非常有效。最终法兰克人别无选择只能投降，你可能会认为尤利安会把他们斩尽杀绝，但他并没有这样做。他把他们安置在
the northernmost line of the Roman Empire, so kind of by the mouth of the Rhine, to serve as allies of the Roman people, what the Romans called foi derati. And the following summer, so the summer of 358, there are more Frankish warbands who intrude. Julian defeats them again, and again he settles them in, you know, what are now the low countries. So some people might think that's very peculiar behaviour. This not unprecedented tactic that the Romans have of taking warlike peoples on their periphery and actually settling them and trying to sort of tame them and to use them. So I guess we'll get into that in a
罗马帝国的最北端边界，也就是莱茵河口附近，让他们充当罗马人民的同盟者，罗马人称之为“同盟者”（foederati）。而在接下来的夏天，也就是公元358年的夏天，还有更多的法兰克战帮闯入。尤利安再次击败了他们，并且再次把他们安置在如今的低地国家。所以有些人可能会觉得这种行为非常奇特。罗马人在其边境地区接纳好战民族并实际安置他们、试图驯服和利用他们，这种策略并非前所未有。所以我想我们一会儿会深入探讨这一点。
second. Before we do that, what do we know of these people, the Franks? I read in your notes, appearance colon terrifying. Now is that just Roman propaganda or are they genuinely scary looking people? I think they are genuinely scary looking. You know, they want to kind of scarify. They make themselves look as intimidating as possible. So we have a record of how they looked to a Roman poet writing in the following century, so in the fifth. You might say it's propaganda, but I don't think so. This poet writes, These monsters have red hair which descends from the top of the skull in a knot, while the back of their head is shaved and shines baldly. So they look Scottish.
在此之前，我们对这些被称为法兰克人的人了解多少？我在你的笔记里读到，外貌这一栏写着：极其恐怖。这只是罗马的政治宣传，还是他们真的是长相吓人的人？我认为他们确实长相吓人。你知道的，他们想要进行某种文身或惊吓装饰。他们让自己看起来尽可能具有恐吓性。因此，我们有关于他们在下一个世纪（即5世纪）的一位罗马诗人眼中长相的记录。你可能会说这是政治宣传，但我认为不是。这位诗人写道：“这些怪物有着红色的头发，头发从头顶扎成一个发髻垂下，而脑后则被剃光，光亮照人。”所以他们看起来像苏格兰人。
Yes, I suppose. They're clean shaven, this poet writes, except for locks of hair which descend from the nose and are combed. So again this is something we've talked about before on the podcast, the inability of the Romans to find a word for what we would call mustaches. A lock of hair which descends from the nose. Yeah. Surely the Romans must be aware that hair grows under your nose. No, they don't have a word for it.
是的，我想是的。这位诗人写道，他们刮得精光，除了从鼻子向下延伸并梳理好的几绺头发。所以这也是我们以前在播客中讨论过的一个问题，罗马人无法为我们所谓的“胡子”找到一个词。一绺从鼻子向下延伸的头发。是的。罗马人肯定知道头发是长在你鼻子底下的吧？不，他们没有一个词来形容它。
And also the detail that they comb it. And then this brilliant detail detail the clothes they wear over their immense genitals are exceedingly tight. Right. So yeah, like a kind of like a prog rocker or something from the 1970s. Yes and also like prog rockers they have fearsome throwing axes. Right and massive mustaches so yeah it's very Genesis circa 1973. So the Franks are not, I guess, a tribe in the way that the Romans of earlier centuries would have recognised the tribe. They're a kind of confederation. That is a pattern that has been developing over the course of the centuries, because the impact of Roman gold, of Roman
还有细节说他们把头发梳理过。然后这个精彩的细节是：他们穿在巨大的生殖器外面的衣服极其紧身。没错。所以，是的，就像某种前卫摇滚乐手或者20世纪70年代的某种人物。是的，而且就像前卫摇滚乐手一样，他们有可怕的投掷斧。没错，还有巨大的胡子，所以是的，这非常像1973年左右的创世纪乐队（Genesis）。所以法兰克人我想并不是那种早期世纪的罗马人所能识别的那种部落。他们是一种联盟。这是几个世纪以来一直在发展的一种模式，因为罗马黄金、罗马
military techniques, but also of the desire of the Romans to understand barbarian peoples in a way that corresponds to the Roman world vision has kind of been creating ever larger tribal entities across the Rhine. The Romans have basically invented these peoples in a way. I think the Germanic peoples start to recognize the Roman standards as the measure to which they should conform and so they start to mould themselves into people like the Romans, which of course makes them actually, ironically, much more menacing. So the Alemanni who we mentioned, I mean that is all the men, that's all the people who've been gathered together. They're a particularly large confederation. The Franks compared to the Alemanni are not as large, certainly not
军事技术的影响，以及罗马人希望以符合罗马世界观的方式理解蛮族民族的愿望，一直在莱茵河畔创造出越来越大的部族实体。罗马人基本上以这种方式发明了这些民族。我认为日耳曼民族开始将罗马的标准视为他们应该遵从的尺度，因此他们开始把自己塑造得像罗马人一样，当然，这实际上具有讽刺意味地使他们变得更加具有威胁性。所以我们提到的阿勒曼尼人，我的意思是那是所有人，那是所有聚集在一起的人。他们是一个特别庞大的联盟。与阿勒曼尼人相比，法兰克人规模没那么大，当然也没有
as large as the most famous confederations of all. So the Goths, the Visigoths, the Western Goths, the Ostrogoths, the Eastern Goths, compared to them they're low rent. And I think that that is why Julian and other Roman emperors and generals are prepared to kind of install them along the frontier as foyer de rati, as allies. And as I said, this is a process that doesn't begin with Julian. It goes back to the third century. So from the late third century, we have a funerary inscription in which the buried warrior has written, I belong to the Frankish nation, but as a soldier under arms, I am a Roman.
所有联盟中最著名的那些大。比如哥特人、西哥特人（西方哥特人）、东哥特人（东方哥特人），跟他们比起来，法兰克人简直是低端货。我想这就是为什么尤利安和其他罗马皇帝与将军们愿意将他们作为同盟者（foederati）安置在边境沿线。正如我所说，这个过程并不是从尤利安开始的。它一直可以追溯到3世纪。因此，从3世纪后期开始，我们有一块葬铭，里面写着埋葬的战士写道：“我属于法兰克民族，但作为一名武装士兵，我是一个罗马人。”
So there you have this idea that you can be both a Frank and a Roman. Even under Constantine, a Frank is registered as having served as a general in the Roman army. And I think that reflects the fact that there is something in this trade off for both peoples, because just as the Franks get the benefits of Roman civilization, you know, wine and central heating and all that kind of stuff. So the Romans get these fearsome guys with their very tight pants and their throwing axes to fill a massive manpower shortage. There are a lack of people who want to serve in the Roman army and the Franks are kind of brilliant at that. And the broader question of who the Franks are, where they come from, this is one that the Franks themselves later will struggle to answer. So one story which will develop much later is that they come from a place called Pannonia, which is
所以你这里就有了这种观念：你既可以是一个法兰克人，也可以是一个罗马人。甚至在君士坦丁统治时期，也有法兰克人被登记为曾在罗马军队中担任将军。我认为这反映了这样一个事实：这种权衡对两个民族来说都有利，因为正如法兰克人获得了罗马文明的好处（葡萄酒、中央供暖等等）一样，罗马人也得到了这些穿着极其紧身裤、拿着投掷斧的可怕家伙，来填补巨大的劳动力短缺。缺乏愿意在罗马军队服役的人，而法兰克人在这方面非常出色。关于法兰克人是谁、他们从哪里来的更广泛问题，这是法兰克人自己后来也会努力去解答的问题。所以后来发展出的一个故事是，他们来自一个叫做潘诺尼亚的地方，也就是
basically the Great Plains of Hungary. But I think that's unlikely because it's telling that that's where the Goths come from. So basically the Franks are identifying themselves with the Goths. And then much later, there's an even more improbable claim that the Franks came from Troy, which of course is where the Romans also came from. Yeah, of course. So they're equating themselves to the Romans.
基本上是匈牙利大平原。但我觉得这不太可能，因为这说明那是哥特人来的地方。所以基本上法兰克人是在把他们自己和哥特人等同起来。然后到了更晚的时候，有一个更加不可信的说法，即法兰克人来自特洛伊，当然这也是罗马人来的地方。对，当然。所以他们是在把自己与罗马人等同起来。
So basically, I think what that tells you is that the Franks are pretty low rent as a group of people. They don't have a distinguished ancestry. They can't really remember where they come from and even the name that they give themselves, so Franks means literally the brave ones, the war hungry ones, in due course they will say that the Franks means the free ones but that is actually under the Romans exactly what they are not. They're not free, they are subordinate. So it's a window, isn't it, into the Roman
所以基本上，我认为这告诉你的事情是，作为一个族群，法兰克人相当低端。他们没有显赫的祖先，他们其实记不清自己来自何方，甚至连他们给自己起的名字——法兰克人字面意思是勇敢的人、渴望战争的人——在到期的时候他们会说法兰克人意思是自由的人，但实际上在罗马人统治下他们恰恰不是这样。他们不是自由的，他们是从属的。所以这是一个窗口，不是吗，让我们得以窥见罗马
world in this period where the empire has come under enormous pressure on the frontiers. And as a part of that, the army is becoming ever more the domain of – historians are a little bit wary of using these terms now, aren't they, like barbarians – basically Germanic peoples are now serving the army in large numbers. And the frontiers owns lots of Germanic peoples who have been settled, kind of slightly military settlements. A lot of the officers are Germanic backgrounds and more like the emperors by now are less and less your kind of pampered Italians and they're more and more your kind of Balkan strongmen and things. And it's a sort of story about the militarisation of the Roman Empire, isn't
在这个时期的世界，帝国在边境上面临着巨大的压力。作为其中的一部分，军队越来越多地成为——历史学家现在对使用这些术语有点谨慎，不是吗，比如蛮族——基本上日耳曼民族现在在军队中大量服役。边境上有许多已经安顿下来的日耳曼民族，某种程度上是军事定居点。许多军官都有日耳曼背景，而且现在的皇帝越来越少是那种养尊处优的意大利人，越来越多是那种巴尔干强人等等。这可以说是关于罗马帝国军事化的故事，
it, I guess? I think there's a real kind of reversal story about the militarisation of the Roman Empire, isn't it, I guess? I think there's a real kind of reversal of what happened early in the Roman Empire, where the army which is stationed along the Rhine is basically the agent of turning these frontier regions Roman. Increasingly, in the third, the fourth, the fifth centuries, the army, because it is becoming more and more barbarian, is barbarianizing those frontier regions. But that doesn't mean that the Franks are the equivalent of the warriors in the Trojan Halls waiting to come out and destroy the Roman Empire.
对吧？我认为关于罗马帝国军事化的故事有一个真正的逆转，不是吗，我想是的。我认为罗马帝国早期发生的事情有一个真正的逆转，当时驻扎在莱茵河沿线的军队基本上是使这些边境地区罗马化的代理人。在3世纪、4世纪、5世纪，军队由于越来越蛮族化，反而在使这些边境地区蛮族化。但这并不意味着法兰克人就等于特洛伊大厅里等待出来摧毁罗马帝国的勇士。
So they're not the enemy within? They're not the enemy within. Because actually, by the end of the fourth century, they are clearly very loyal as foederati. By the end of the fourth century, they've been serving Rome for several generations. They are even willing to fight other Franks who lie beyond the Roman frontier. And I think they remain loyal basically because they're warlords, they're leaders remain loyal.
所以他们不是内部的敌人？他们不是内部的敌人。因为实际上，到4世纪末，他们作为同盟者显然非常忠诚。到4世纪末，他们已经为罗马效力了好几代人。他们甚至愿意与罗马边境之外的其他法兰克人作战。我认为他们保持忠诚基本上是因为他们的军阀、他们的领袖保持着忠诚。
And these Frankish leaders, on the one hand, they are very, very Roman. They speak Latin, they read Virgil, they're highly cultured. The gods that they worship are the traditional Roman gods. But at the same time, their authority depends on the fact that they are Frankish warlords, that they are respected by their troops. And so you have this sense of a Romano-Frankish identity, which doesn't really require the warlords or indeed their soldiers to choose between the Franks or the Romans. In what way then are they not Roman? Because their lingua franca is a Germanic language? Because they have their mustaches? Because they have a mustache, they have their tiepans.
这些法兰克领袖一方面非常非常罗马化。他们说拉丁语，读维吉尔，极具文化修养。他们崇拜的神是传统的罗马神灵。但与此同时，他们的权威取决于这样一个事实：他们是法兰克军阀，他们受到军队的尊敬。因此，你拥有了一种罗马-法兰克身份认同感，这实际上并不需要军阀或他们的士兵在法兰克人和罗马人之间二选一。那么他们在什么意义上不是罗马人呢？因为他们的通用语是日耳曼语？因为他们留着胡子？因为他们留着胡子，穿着紧身裤。
I think their leaders are able to kind of migrate between both worlds. I think the mass of the warriors are kind of more recognisably Germanic, but they are absolutely integrated into the Roman military system. And so that means that in the early fifth century, when basically the Rhine frontier collapses, the Franks are very implicated in the kind of the great catastrophe, the great drama of this story. So the highlights of this process, 406, you get large groups of barbarians crossing the Rhine. 410, the Visigoths sack Rome. The following year in 411, a great confederation called the Burgundians cross the Rhine, conquer stretches of the river, and they conquer all the regions that Julian had been defending
我认为他们的领袖能够在两个世界之间游走。我认为广大士兵的日耳曼特征更明显一些，但他们绝对已经融入了罗马的军事系统。这意味着在5世纪初，当莱茵河边境基本上崩溃时，法兰克人深深卷入了这场故事的大灾难和宏大戏剧中。所以这个过程的高光时刻是，406年，大批蛮族跨越莱茵河。410年，西哥特人洗劫罗马。第二年，即411年，一个名为勃艮第人的庞大联盟跨越莱茵河，征服了河段的土地，他们征服了尤利安在50年前一直保卫的所有地区，
50 years previously, so including Strasbourg. And this is a situation in which the Franks have to play a crucial part because they have to decide where their loyalties lie. Does it lie with the imploding Roman Empire or does it lie with the Germanic peoples? Right, because when the institutions fall apart, the people with all the weapons and the military know-how are suddenly in an incredibly powerful position, aren't they? Absolutely. I mean, they will literally become the kingmakers in the post-Roman world. And indeed, in due course, become the kings. So they are going to play a key part in this process of transformation, which takes place through the fifth century. But before we get to that,
包括斯特拉斯堡。在这种情况下，法兰克人必须扮演至关重要的角色，因为他们必须决定自己的忠诚在何方。是效忠于正在内爆的罗马帝国，还是效忠于日耳曼民族？没错，因为当体制崩溃时，那些拥有所有武器和军事专长的人突然处于一个极其有利的位置，不是吗？当然。我的意思是，他们将成为后罗马世界中名副其实的造王者。事实上，假以时日，他们自己也会成为国王。因此，他们将在5世纪发生的这个转型过程中扮演关键角色。但在我们讨论到那一点之前，
there is also another massive process of transformation that's been taking place in the Roman Empire in the fourth and into the fifth century. And this also will have a transformative impact on the Franks over the course of the succeeding centuries. And again, I think the best way to kind of introduce this great transformation is to go back to the 350s and the campaigns of Julian in Gaul because there is one particular soldier who is serving with Julian's armies
罗马帝国在4世纪和5世纪也正在经历另一个大规模的转型过程。这也会对接下来几个世纪中法兰克人产生变革性的影响。同样，我认为介绍这一宏大转型的最好方法是回到350年代尤利安在高卢的战役，因为有一名特定的士兵正随尤利安的军队在那场战役中服役，
in that campaign and this is a man from Pannonia, so from the Hungarian plain, a man of pretty humble lineage, certainly not high class in any way, and he is called Martinus, or as we would call him today, Martin. And he is stationed one winter in Amiens, which is very much in the region where the Franks are being stationed as well, so kind of what's now northeastern France. Shall I read what happened to him, Tom? Would you enjoy that? I would, because I actually wrote it. It's in Dominion. I'll read it with the respect it deserves.
这个人来自潘诺尼亚，也就是匈牙利平原，出身相当卑微，绝对谈不上什么高贵阶层，他叫马丁努斯，或者按我们今天的叫法，马丁。有年冬天他驻扎在亚眠，这个地方非常靠近法兰克人也被安置的区域，也就是现在法国的东北部。托姆，要不我来读读他身上发生了什么？你会喜欢听吗？我很乐意，因为其实就是我写的。那在《统治》里。我将带着应有的敬意来朗读它。
The cold that year was exceptionally better. A beggar in rags stood shivering by the gateway of the city. His fellow townsmen wrapped up warm as they crunched through the snow, gave him nothing. Then came Martin. Dressed for duty, he had no money, only his arms. As a soldier, though, he did have his heavy military cloak, and so taking out his sword, he cut it in two and gave half to the beggar. The following night Martin had a dream. He saw Christ dressed in the very portion of the cloak that he had given away that day. And the Lord said to him as he had done on earth, whatever you did for one of the least of these brothers of mine, you did for me."
那年的寒冷异常刺骨。一个衣衫褴褛的乞丐在城市大门旁瑟瑟发抖。他的同城人在踩着积雪嘎吱作响、裹得严严实实走过时，什么也没给他。然后马丁来了。身穿戎装的他没有钱，只有武器。作为一名士兵，他确实有厚重的军呢斗篷，于是他拔出剑，把它切成两半，把一半给了乞丐。第二天晚上，马丁做了一个梦。他看到基督穿着他那天送出去的那部分斗篷。主对他在人世间一样对他说：‘凡你对我这些最小的兄弟中的一个所做的，就是对我做的。’”
That's how Jesus speaks, is it? Oh, that's such a moving story. And I bet that really happened. So a very dramatic moment, Christ appearing to the soldier Martin who's given away half of his cloak. And Martin is convinced by this appearance of Christ essentially to give up on his military career. So he's offered a donative by Julian along with all his other men and he refuses to accept it and he demands to be released from the army. And he supposedly tells Julian until now it is you I have served from this moment on, I am a servant of Christ.
耶稣说话就是这个调调吗？哦，这是一个多么感人的故事。我敢打赌这真的是发生了。所以这是一个非常戏剧性的时刻，基督向送出一半斗篷的士兵马丁显灵。马丁被基督的这次显灵彻底说服，决定放弃他的军事生涯。因此尤利安向他以及他所有的部下提供赏金，但他拒绝接受，并要求退伍。据说他告诉尤利安：到目前为止我服侍的是你，从这一刻起，我是基督的仆人。
I bet Julian didn't like that. That was a shocking display of laisse-majeste. The truth is Dominic, that it is Martin and not Julian who embodies the future, because Julian is better known as Julian the Apostate, the last emperor to worship the traditional Roman gods. Yeah. And Martin, of course, is a Christian and the future of the Roman Empire is a Christian one.
我敢打赌尤利安不会喜欢那样。那是一种令人震惊的对最高权力的蔑视。多米尼克，事实是，是马丁而不是尤利安体现了未来，因为尤利安更广为人知的身份是“背教者尤利安”，最后一位崇拜传统罗马神灵的皇帝。是的。而马丁当然是一位基督徒，罗马帝国的未来是属于基督教的。
Oh, the irony. But the thing about Martin is that he is a Christian of a peculiarly radical kind, because even though Julian is very hostile to Christianity, Constantius, his cousin, he's a Christian. Most of the Roman elites are starting to kind of jump ship and become Christian. They can tell the way that the wind is blowing. And when they become Christian, they don't give up their wealth or their snobbery or their kind of contempt for the poor. Instead, they see the church as another opportunity for self-advancement. So whereas a previous generation of the elite might have become consuls or whatever, now
哦，真是讽刺。但关于马丁的事实是，他是一个具有特殊激进色彩的基督徒，因为尽管尤利安对基督教非常敌视，但他的堂弟君士坦提乌斯是一名基督徒。大多数罗马精英开始跳船转投基督教。他们能看出风向。当他们成为基督徒时，他们并没有放弃自己的财富、势利或对穷人的蔑视。相反，他们将教会视为另一个自我晋升的机会。因此，上一代的精英可能会成为执政官或类似的角色，而现在
they might become bishops because to be a bishop is to be in the late Roman Empire, the Christianising Roman Empire, is to be a figure of immense authority and power. And they retain all the appurtenances of power. They keep their palaces, they keep their slaves, they keep their fine clothes. But Martin, that's not what he's into at all. He completely rejects this kind of conviction that you can be Christian and be rich. So an admirer of his, who is himself an aristocrat, who is converted to Martin's understanding of Christianity, writes of Martin, his looks were those of a peasant, his clothes shoddy, his hair a disgrace. And Martin's ambition is to become what the Greeks call
他们可能会成为主教，因为在晚期罗马帝国、基督教化罗马帝国中，成为主教意味着成为一个拥有巨大权威和权力的人物。他们保留了权力的所有外在表象。他们保留了宫殿、奴隶和华丽的衣服。但马丁完全不是这样的人。他彻底拒绝了“你可以既当基督徒又很富有”这种信念。因此，他的一位崇拜者，他本人是一位皈依了马丁对基督教理解的贵族，这样写道：“马丁的外表像个农民，衣服破烂不堪，头发糟糕透顶。”而马丁的志向是成为希腊人所称的
a monarchus, so literally one who lives alone, i.e. a monk. And he's one of the first monks in the western half of the empire because they kind of originate in the eastern half. And he settles on a grassy plain named Mamutie which is three miles downriver from the the Gallic town of Tor and he subjects himself to incredible austerity so as a soldier of course you know he'd gone through vigorous military training but now as a monk he's basically living on nothing, he's enduring extremes of cold and heat, living a very, very tough life. But this becomes a source of huge admiration for lots of people in Gaul.
“monarchus”，也就是字面上的“独自生活的人”，即修士。他是帝国西半部的第一批修士之一，因为他们起源于东半部。他定居在一个名为马穆蒂（Mamutie）的草地上，该地位于图尔（Tour）高卢城镇下游三英里处，他让自己经受了难以置信的苦行——作为一名士兵，当然，你知道他经历过严格的军事训练，但现在作为一名修士，他基本上过着一无所有的生活，忍受着极端的冷热，过着非常非常艰难的生活。但这成了高卢许多人极度钦佩的源泉。
So there are people in the elites who come to admire him not despite but because of his rejection of everything that they represent, all the kind of, you know, the worldly standards of greatness. And it wins him the ability to perform spectacular miracles that further kind of increases his fame. And so you start to get people of immensely wealthy backgrounds giving up the kind of traditional path to greatness and to rank and coming to join him and they camp out in caves or in wooden shacks. Just a question about the miracles. What are the miracles? He's healing the sick, people with twisted limbs, he's straightening them, he's giving sight to the blind,
因此，精英阶层中有人开始钦佩他，不是尽管他拒绝了他所代表的一切、所有世俗的伟大标准，而是正是因为这种拒绝。这为他赢得了展现壮观神迹的能力，进一步提升了他的名声。于是你开始看到出身极其富贵背景的人放弃通往伟大和阶层的传统道路，前来加入他，他们露营在山洞或木屋里。关于神迹我有个问题。神迹是什么？他在治愈病人，肢体扭曲的人，他把他们拉直，让盲人复明，
he's giving voice to the mute. Wow, amazing. Absolutely happening and the proof of this Dominic, and I can see you looking skeptical, is that in 371 Martin is elected as the Bishop of Tor and this is absolutely stupefying because as we've been saying bishops are people from the absolute elite of society and it comes as a complete shock to the elites but it also comes as a shock to Martin who doesn't want to be a bishop at all and he runs away and hides himself in a barn and the geese go and tell the people who've elected him where he is and so he has to come out and become a bishop.
让哑者开口。哇，太惊人了！绝对发生了，多米尼克的证据是——我能看出你持怀疑态度——在371年，马丁被选为图尔的主教，这绝对是令人瞠目结舌的，因为正如我们所说，主教是社会绝对精英阶层出身的人，这对精英阶层来说是个完全的震惊，但对马丁来说也是个震惊，他根本不想当主教，他逃跑并把自己藏在一个谷仓里，而鹅跑去告诉那些选他的人他在哪里，所以他不得不出来当主教。
Are they? It's just a small thing but how do the geese communicate to those people? They honk. Okay, they just honk and people interpret it as they... Yeah, they honk. They honk and hiss. Okay. Yeah, they're not talking.
是吗？这只是个小问题，但鹅是怎么跟那些人交流的？它们叫。好吧，它们只是叫，然后人们将其解释为……是的，它们叫。它们发出叫声和嘶嘶声。好吧。是的，它们不会说话。
No. That would be too miraculous. Okay. So anyway, but the miracles continue and this means that Martin, you know, he has a source of power that does not derive from the traditional standards of Roman life. It's coming directly from heaven. And so that means that his person is charged with an incredible source of power. And it means that when he dies, his body, his relics will continue to be a source of
不。那太神奇了。好吧。无论如何，神迹仍在继续，这意味着马丁（你知道的）拥有了一种权力来源，它并非源自罗马生活的传统标准。它直接来自天堂。这意味着他的人被赋予了一种不可思议的力量之源。这也意味着当他死后，他的身体、他的圣物将继续成为
power. And so he dies in his cell and two groups of people, one from Tours and one from the neighbouring city of Poitiers, they both decide that they would like to have the body and so they all camp outside his cell and the people of Poitiers basically block off the entrance so that the people of Tours can't get in and stand guard over it. But they then all fall asleep and the people of Tours who've stayed awake, they sneak in through the window, grab the body, take it to Tours in great triumph and they keep it there. And so from that point on, the relics of Martin are kept at Tours.
力量之源。所以他在他的单人囚室里去世了，两群人——一群来自图尔，另一群来自邻近的普瓦捷城市——都决定他们想要得到这具尸体，于是他们都在他的单人囚室外扎营，普瓦捷的人基本上封锁了入口，这样图尔的人就进不去，并在尸体旁守卫。但随后他们都睡着了，而保持清醒的图尔人从窗户偷偷溜进去，抢走了尸体，带着巨大的凯旋将其带回图尔并留在了那里。因此从那时起，马丁的圣物就一直保存在图尔。
Isn't it a funny thought that if that little confrontation worked out differently, the French might not have shamed themselves in 1356, the Battle of Pratier, because he would have been on their side. Well, Dominic, it's another example for French history of people falling asleep at Inoptitian times. It is, like the Marquis de Lafayette. Very sad. So Martin's body is taken in triumph to Tours. The people are thrilled to have it. The elites of Tours less so, the bishop, for instance, who succeeds Martin, he's very sniffy about it. You know, he builds a small shrine over Martin's tomb, but he doesn't do anything much more than that. And essentially to the elites for several generations, Martin remains an embarrassment,
这是一个多么有趣的奇想：如果那场小冲突的结果有所不同，法国人可能就不会在1356年的普瓦捷战役中让自己蒙羞了，因为他会站在他们那边。嗯，多米尼克，这是法国历史上人们在不合时宜的时候睡着又一个例子。确实如此，就像拉法耶特侯爵一样。真让人难过。因此，马丁的尸体被凯旋运往图尔。人们为拥有它而欣喜若狂。图尔的精英们则不那么高兴，例如接替马丁的主教对此非常挑剔。你知道的，他在马丁的墓上建造了一个小神殿，但除此之外他没有做更多的事情。基本上，对于好几代精英来说，马丁仍然是一个尴尬的存在，
but his relics do continue to perform miracles and his fame grows and grows and grows. And essentially he embodies a kind of source of power that is so uncanny, so unsettling that the Christian elites of Gaul don't quite know what to do with it. It's in excess of their ability to control. But a time is approaching when a new people will emerge as the Masters of Gaul and they will recognise in Martin exactly what they need. A celestial patron who has been despised by the traditional Masters of Gaul but is perfectly suited to their needs and those people of course are the Franks. What a cliffhanger. So return after the break to find out how the Franks continue their rise to become the Warlords of the West. Now Tom, we have something unbelievably exciting to share with our
但他的圣物确实继续显现神迹，他的名声越来越大。本质上，他体现了一种如此诡异、如此令人不安的力量源泉，以至于高卢的基督教精英们根本不知道该拿它怎么办。这超出了他们控制的能力。但一个新时代即将来临，一个新民族将崛起成为高卢的主人，他们将在马丁身上准确地认出他们所需要的东西：一个被高卢传统主人所鄙视但完美契合他们需求的星际守护神，而这个民族当然就是法兰克人。真是个扣人心弦的悬念。请在休息后回来，了解法兰克人如何继续崛起，成为西方军阀的。托姆，我们有什么难以置信的令人兴奋的事情要跟我们的
listeners don't we? Absolutely we do Dominic. We are announcing the launch of the Rest is History merchandise. Yes, you can now own a piece of history. Literally. We've got shirts, mugs, phone cases, notebooks, so much just in time for Christmas. Unbelievable scenes Tom because these aren't just any shirts and mugs. Tom, these are exclusive Rest is History designs. That's right Dominic. And our new merch truly is the perfect gift for any history fan, whether they're a friend of the show or dare we say someone who's not yet a friend of the show. Yeah, I mean this is an unbelievably cunning wheeze isn't it? Really is.
听众分享的，对吧？绝对是的，多米尼克。我们正在宣布推出《历史其余部分》周边商品。是的，你现在可以拥有一件历史了。字面意义上的。我们有T恤、马克杯、手机壳、笔记本，应有尽有，正好赶上圣诞节。难以置信的场景，托姆，因为这些可不仅仅是普通的T恤和马克杯。托姆，这些是《历史其余部分》的独家设计。没错，多米尼克。我们的新周边确实是送给任何历史迷的完美礼物，无论他们是节目的朋友，还是——我们敢说——尚未成为节目的朋友的人。是的，我的意思是这是一个令人难以置信的精明诡计，对吧？真的是这样。
Because if you're a loyal friend of the show, you can buy a t-shirt that proudly declares your allegiance. And if you still need convincing, then you can buy a not a friend of the show version as well. So truly, it's beyond a dream gift, isn't it? And we'll be sharing on social media our favourite pictures of you in your Restless History merch. So send these in over Christmas morning. So remember to head to www.goalhanger.shop to get your merch. Christ's lineage was in perpetual danger. The early church feared that if the lineage
因为如果你是节目的忠实朋友，你可以买一件自豪地宣告你效忠的T恤。如果你仍然需要被说服，那么你也可以买一件“不是节目的朋友”版本的。所以真的，这超越了一份梦想中的礼物，不是吗？我们将在社交媒体上分享你穿着《历史其余部分》周边的最爱照片。所以请在圣诞节早晨把这些发过来。所以请记住前往 www.goalhanger.shop 获取你的周边。基督的血脉处于永恒的危险之中。早期教会担心，如果这种血脉
were permitted to grow, the secret of Jesus and Magdalene would eventually surface and challenge the fundamental Catholic doctrine, that of a divine messiah who did not consort with women or engage in sexual union." He paused. Nonetheless, Christ's line grew quietly undercover in France until making a bold move in the 5th century, when it intermarried with French royal blood and created a lineage known as the Merovingian bloodline. So those are the unmistakable tones of Gandalf, aka Ian McKellen, playing Salih Tebing. And that is of course the unmistakable prose of very much a, I don't think friend is the right word, but he's an associate, isn't he? He's an associate to the rest of history. And that is the acclaimed novelist,
得以繁衍，耶稣和抹大拉的秘密最终会浮出水面，并挑战天主教的核心教义——即一位不与女人交往也不发生性结合的神圣弥赛亚。”他停顿了一下。尽管如此，基督的血脉在法国隐蔽地悄然成长，直到在5世纪采取了大胆的一步，当时它与法国皇室血脉通婚，创造了一个被称为墨洛温王朝血脉的家族。”所以这些是甘道夫无可误认的语调，也就是伊恩·麦克莱恩饰演的萨利·提宾。当然，这也是某人的无可误认的散文，我觉得“朋友”这个词不太对，但他是个熟人，对吧？他是《历史其余部分》的一个熟人。这就是广受赞誉的小说家、
renowned novelist, Dan Brown in The Da Vinci Code. And Salih Tee being there for people who are just absolutely baffled, he's explaining how Christ's descendants have intermarried with the Merovingian bloodline. And this is the royal dynasty that comes to rule the Franks and they're basically all descended from Jesus and Mary Magdalene. And like so many things in this story, this absolutely definitely happened, didn't it Tom? So people who haven't read the Da Vinci Code or seen it or read the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, which is the book purporting to be history on which the Da Vinci Code was based. The theory in this is that Jesus and Mary Magdalene get married, they have children, this is a holy
著名小说家丹·布朗在《达·芬奇密码》中的描写。对于那些感到彻底困惑的人来说，萨利·提宾在那里解释了基督的后代是如何与墨洛温血脉通婚的。这就是统治法兰克人的皇室王朝，他们基本上都是耶稣和抹大拉的后代。就像这个故事中的许多事情一样，这绝对是发生了，对吧，托姆？所以那些没有读过《达·芬奇密码》或看过它，或者读过《圣血与圣杯》（即《达·芬奇密码》所依据的自称历史的书籍）的人。这里的理论是，耶稣和抹大拉结婚了，他们有了孩子，这是一个神圣的
bloodline, sangrial, the holy blood, and that as Liti Bing says that it marries into Frankish royalty and they create this family called the Merovingians. And you may wonder where has this come from? And the answer is that there's a Frankish chronicle which is written in the seventh century, which claims that the Merovingians who are absolutely a historical dynasty will be looking at them, that they took their name from a guy called Merovech, who was a Frankish king whose mother had been out for swim in the ocean where she had encountered a mysterious sea creature that was part sea monster, part human and part bull. It's kind of hard to picture that, isn't it? Part bull. Which bit of him is bull? Which
血脉（sangrial，即圣血），正如提宾所说，它与法兰克皇室联姻，创造了这个名为墨洛温王朝的家族。你可能想知道这从何而来？答案是，有一部在7世纪编写的法兰克编年史，声称绝对是历史王朝的墨洛温家族——我们将审视他们——他们的名字取自一个名叫墨洛维（Merovech）的人，他是一位法兰克国王，他的母亲曾在海洋中游泳，在那里她遇到了一种神秘的海洋生物，它部分是海怪、部分是人类、部分是公牛。这有点难以想象，对吧？部分是公牛。它的哪部分是公牛？哪
bit of him is human and which is sea monster? I don't think that is explained. But according to the Holy Blood and the Holy Grail, which informs Dan Brown's novel, this sea creature was actually a fish and an early Christian symbol for Jesus was a fish. Yeah, still is. And so that proves that the Merovingians are actually... So this creature was Jesus. Yeah, it's said to be Jesus. That's a shock, isn't it, if that's what Jesus looks like. So that's the theory, but there is an alternative, and I would say likelier, explanation. Ah, that's disappointing. What's this alternative and no doubt very drab explanation? And the explanation probably is that Merovich, if he existed at all, was a Frankish leader
他哪部分是人类，哪部分又是海怪？我觉得这并没有解释清楚。但根据《圣血与圣杯》这本为丹·布朗的小说提供灵感的书，这个海怪实际上是一条鱼，而早期基督教中耶稣的象征就是一条鱼。是的，现在依然是。所以这就证明了墨洛温王朝实际上……所以这个生物就是耶稣。是的，据说就是耶稣。这挺让人震惊的，对吧，如果耶稣长成那样的话。这就是理论所在，但还有一个替代的、我也觉得更有可能的解释。啊，真让人失望。这个毫无疑问非常枯燥的替代解释是什么呢？这个解释很可能是，墨洛维奇如果真的存在的话，他是一位法兰克首领
who was a Roman voiderati commander in the age of Attila and he fights with the Romans against Attila in the great battle that sees the Huns turn back. But equally, I mean, he may have been completely legendary. There's all kinds of debate about this among historians. But in either case, I mean, people may be wondering where on earth did this kind of mad story about the sea monster come from? and I think it comes from the fact that over the course of the fifth century and definitely into the sixth century these Frankish warlords who previously had proclaimed their power in Roman terms are having to find alternative sources to manifest their greatness and essentially they are looking for ways to market themselves as kingly and to have a kind of mad origin point, a third bull, a third human, a third sea monster. I mean
在阿提拉时代，他曾是罗马的同盟者（Foederati）指挥官，他在那场迫使匈人撤退的伟大战役中与罗马人并肩作战，对抗阿提拉。但同样地，我的意思是，他可能完全是一个传奇人物。历史学家们对此有各种各样的争论。但无论哪种情况，我是说，人们可能会想，关于海怪的这个疯狂故事到底是从哪里来的呢？我认为它源于这样一个事实：在公元五世纪乃至进入六世纪的过程中，这些法兰克军阀此前曾以罗马的方式宣扬他们的权力，现在却不得不寻找替代的来源来彰显他们的伟大，本质上，他们正在寻找将自己包装成国王身份的方法，并拥有一个某种疯狂的起源点——三分之一是公牛，三分之一是人类，三分之一是海怪。我的意思是
that's a great way to say that you belong to a dynasty that is somehow kind of out of the ordinary and we know that by the end of the fifth century Frankish warlords are starting to proclaim themselves kings. And the first person that we absolutely know did this is a guy called Childeric, who'd been a commander of Frankish Foederati. He may actually have been a son of Merovich, there are historians who argue this, and he is taking on himself all the symbols of royalty. So among the Franks, the particular symbol of royalty is to grow your hair longer than anyone else. So, you know, if you're the guy in the prog rock band, your hair is right the way down to the back of your knees. And so the Merovingian kings come
这是一种绝佳的方式来宣称你属于一个某种程度上与众不同的王朝，我们知道，到公元五世纪末，法兰克军阀开始自立为王。我们绝对知道的第一个这样做的，是一个叫希尔德里克（Childeric）的人，他曾是法兰克同盟者军队的指挥官。他实际上可能是墨洛维奇的儿子，有历史学家持这种观点，他把所有的王权象征都揽于一身。因此在法兰克人中，王权的特殊象征就是留比任何人都长的头发。所以，如果你是前卫摇滚乐队里的那个家伙，你的头发一直垂到膝盖后面。因此，墨洛温王朝的国王们
to be called the Reges Criniti, the long-haired kings. And the reason that we know that Childeric called himself a king is that his tomb was found near Tournai in Belgium in 1653 and it was kind of full of sumptuous grave goods. He had this cloak that was decorated with lots of golden bees and these golden bees actually provided Napoleon with the symbol for the French Empire that he wanted. So it was designed to kind of replace the fleur de lis, the royal symbol. And as well as all these golden bees, there was a ring that had the inscription – I belong to Childric the King. So just on this thing about being a king, Childric died in 481 and lots of people listening to this podcast will know that five years earlier, the Roman Empire in the West had
被称为“长发国王”（Reges Criniti）。我们之所以知道希尔德里克自称为王，是因为1653年在比利时的图尔奈附近发现了他的陵墓，里面塞满了奢华的随葬品。他有一件饰有许多金蜜蜂的斗篷，正是这些金蜜蜂为拿破仑提供了他想要的法兰西帝国象征。所以它的设计有点像是为了取代王室象征——百合花饰。除了所有这些金蜜蜂，还有一枚戒指，上面刻着铭文——“属于希尔德里克国王”。说到称王这件事，希尔德里克于481年去世，听这个播客的许多人都会知道，就在五年前，西罗马帝国
formally come to an end. And we always think of this as a massive moment, but actually at the time, probably a lot of people barely even noticed there was no longer an emperor in the West. But that's reflective of a general breakdown across the fifth century in the institutions and the authority of Rome in the Western half of the empire.
正式走到了尽头。我们总是认为这是一个重大的时刻，但实际上在当时，可能很多人甚至几乎没有注意到西方已经没有皇帝了。但这反映了五世纪整个西方帝国境内罗马机构和权威的全面崩溃。
And so, as we said in the first half, when the institutions break down, basically power passes to those people who have weapons and then know how to use them. And I guess it's clearly only going to be a matter of time before some of these warlords or officers or captains or gangland mobsters or whatever image you want to use to describe them, before they start to say, well, you know, actually who needs an authority above me? I'll be the top dog and I'll make myself a king. So is that what's going on here that the Franks, they're part of a general pattern of warlords turning themselves into kings? Absolutely. So Jolderic is succeeded by his son who's
因此，正如我们在前半部分所说，当机构崩溃时，权力基本上就转到了那些拥有武器并且知道如何使用它们的人手中。我想这显然只是时间问题，这些军阀、军官、队长、黑帮暴徒，或者你用来形容他们的任何形象，在他们开始说“好吧，实际上谁需要一个在我之上的权威？我来当老大，我自己当国王”之前。那么，这是否意味着法兰克人正在经历这种情况，他们是军阀自立为王这一普遍模式的一部分？完全正确。所以希尔德里克的继承人是他的儿子
a guy called Clovis and Clovis, the great Frankish warlord, proclaimed himself as a king. He's only one of a number of would-be warlords who at this point are scrapping over the corpse of what had been Roman Gaul. The most formidable of these are the Visigoths, the Goths of the West who have conquered much of Spain but they also rule a huge swathe of southern Gaul. There are others as well. So there's the Burgundians who had crossed over the Rhine in 411 and conquered all the area around Strasbourg. There are our friends the Alemanni. They're also very much on the scene. And there is
一个叫克洛維斯（Clovis）的人，伟大的法兰克军阀克洛維斯自立为王。他只是当时争夺罗马高卢尸体的众多潜在军阀之一。其中最强大的是西哥特人，西方的哥特人，他们征服了西班牙的大部分地区，但也统治着南高卢的一大片土地。还有其他人。比如勃艮第人，他们在411年跨越莱因河，征服了斯特拉斯堡周围的所有地区。还有我们的老朋友阿勒曼尼人。他们也大量出现在舞台上。还有
also a Roman renegade, a guy called Siagrius, who calls himself King of the Romans, so Rex Romanarum. And he is Clovis's most immediate rival and neighbour, and the town that he has taken as his capital is a city that from early times in Roman Gaul had been called Lutetia Parisorum, so Lutetia of the Parisi, that's the local Gallic tribe, but which by this point has come to be known as Paris. And so it's unsurprising with Cyagrius right on his doorstep that the first person that Clovis targets is this so-called King of the Romans. And in 486 Clovis wins a great battle at Soissons, defeats Cyagrius, Cyagrius runs away, escapes, he turns up in Toulouse, which is the capital of the Visigoths
一个罗马叛徒，一个叫西亚格里乌斯（Siagrius）的人，他自称罗马人之王，即 Rex Romanarum。他是克洛维斯最直接的对手和邻居，他选作首都的城镇，自罗马高卢早期以来就被称为 Lutetia Parisorum，即巴黎人的吕泰西亚（Lutetia 是当地的高卢部落），但到此时已被人们称为巴黎。因此，鉴于西亚格里乌斯近在咫尺，克洛维斯第一个下手的目标自然就是这位所谓的“罗马人之王”。在486年，克洛维斯在苏瓦松（Soissons）赢得了一场大战，击败了西亚格里乌斯，西亚格里乌斯仓皇逃跑，逃到了图卢兹（Toulouse），那里是西哥特人的首都
in southern Gaul. The Visigothic king returns him to Clovis, who imprisons him and then has him murdered. And you might say that actually, you know, we did a whole series, didn't we, on when the Roman Empire in the west ends. This might be an alternative point because Sagris had been ruling as a Roman and with him gone, there are no more people claiming to rule Gaul in a kind of Roman way. And Paris from now on will be the capital of the Franks. This is where Clovis puts down his own base. So he's conquered northern Gaul with the exception of a Morica of Brittany which he kind of leaves alone. He then decides he's going to advance southwards and try and conquer all these other peoples who are lurking in the south. So his first target are the Alamanni and he defeats them in a
位于南高卢。西哥特国王把他送回给克洛维斯，克洛维斯将他监禁随后下令将其谋杀。你可能会说，实际上，我们做过一整期节目，不是吗？关于西罗马帝国何时终结。这可能是一个替代的时间点，因为西亚格里乌斯曾作为罗马人统治，随着他的离去，再也没有人宣称以罗马的方式统治高卢了。从那时起，巴黎将成为法兰克人的首都。克洛维斯就是在这里建立了自己的基地。所以他征服了北高卢，除了布列塔尼的阿莫里卡（Armorica）他姑且放过不理。接着他决定向南挺进，试图征服所有盘踞在南方的其他部族。所以他的第一个目标是阿勒曼尼人，他在莱茵河畔一个叫
great battle at a place called Tolbiac in the Rhineland. Very, very close run. At one point as we will see Clovis thinks that he's going to lose and he makes a vow that has a seismic impact on the future course of European history but we'll come to that in due course. He then turns on the Burgundians, he forces them to pay him tribute and then finally in 507 he's ready for the big one, the kind of heavyweight championship and that is to take on the Visigoths in the south of Gaul. So he marches southwards just by Poitiers, so very close to Tours, the shrine of St. Martin, to a place called Vouillet.
托尔比亚克（Tolbiac）的地方的一场大战中击败了他们。这是一场非常非常险胜的战役。正如我们接下来会看到的，克洛维斯一度以为自己要输了，于是他许下一个对欧洲历史未来走向产生震撼性影响的誓言，但我们稍后会讲到。接着他掉头对付勃艮第人，强迫他们向自己纳贡，最后在507年，他准备好迎接重头戏——那场类似于重量级拳王争霸赛的战役，那就是攻打南高卢的西哥特人。于是他向南进军，经过普瓦捷（Poitiers）附近，非常靠近图尔（Tours）的圣马丁圣地，来到一个叫武耶（Vouillé）的地方。
He meets the Visigoths under their king. The Visigoths are wiped out. The king is killed. Clovis continues southwards. He lays Toulouse, the Visigothic capital, under siege. 508, Toulouse falls and all that remains to the Visigoths of their former enormous swathes of territory in southern Gaul is a tiny strip of land. And it's an astonishing achievement because
他迎战在他们的国王率领下的西哥特人。西哥特人被全歼。国王被杀。克洛维斯继续向南挺进。他围攻西哥特人的首都图卢兹。508年，图卢兹陷落，西哥特人曾经在南高卢拥有的庞大领土，如今只剩下一条极窄的狭长地带。这是一项令人惊叹的成就，因为
the Franks, who in lots of ways had been the most inferior of all the kind of various Germanic confederations have emerged as the masters of Gaul, the most prosperous of all the provinces in the Western Empire. The lands that for 500 years pretty much had been ruled by the Caesars are now subject to a Germanic warlord who's got his long hair, he's got his enormous genitals bolting out of his tight pants, he's got his bees, he's got all this kind of stuff. And you know, it's quite the transformation. But the counter argument might run like this, that these guys have been serving in the Roman army now for generations. I mean, not talking about decades, we're talking about more than a century.
法兰克人在许多方面曾是各个日耳曼部落联盟中最劣势的，却一跃成为高卢的主人，而高卢是西部帝国中最繁荣的省份。这片被凯撒大帝统治了将近500年的土地，如今落入了一个日耳曼军阀的手中——他留着长头发，紧身裤里鼓囊囊地显露着巨大的生殖器，带着他的蜜蜂，还有诸如此类的种种行头。你知道，这真是一个巨大的转变。但反面的观点可能会这样认为：这些人已经在罗马军队里服役了好几代人了。我的意思是，不是几十年，而是超过一个世纪。
That perhaps to a lot of people, they would look pretty Romanized. That they know how the Roman Empire works because they've been in it for so long. That actually, they are not replacing Roman Roman authority but they're simply succeeding to it. And that possibly to a lot of people, provincial elites and whatnot, these just look like the Imperial Army or people who were once in the Imperial Army have basically moved in and reasserted control. Isn't that how it might look? Well, we know for a fact that it does because we have a letter that is written by the Bishop of Reims in northern Gaul, a guy called Remedius, who is clearly Roman, you can tell that from
也许在许多人看来，他们看起来已经相当“罗马化”了。他们知道罗马帝国是如何运作的，因为他们已经在其中呆了那么久。实际上，他们并没有取代罗马的权威，而是顺理成章地继承了它。可能在许多人（如行省精英等）看来，这些人只是帝国军队，或者曾经在帝国军队里的人基本上搬了进来，重新确立了控制权。难道不应该是这样吗？嗯，我们确凿地知道情况确实如此，因为我们有一封由高卢北部兰斯（Reims）主教写的一封信，那个人叫雷米迪乌斯（Remedius），他显然是个罗马人，你可以从
his name, also very, very holy. He's a man who supposedly can raise the dead back to life. And he writes to Clovis when Clovis succeeds his father Childric, essentially hailing Clovis not as a king, but as the new governor of the Roman province of northeastern Gaul. And we have the letter that he writes to him. And he says, the bestowal of your favour must be pure and honest, you must honour your bishops and must always incline yourself to their advice. And this is exactly as he would have written to a Roman governor. Well, he says it's no surprise you've begun just as your forefathers had always done. Yes.
他的名字看出来，而且非常非常神圣。据说他是一个能让人起死回生的人。当克洛维斯继承他父亲希尔德里克的王位时，他写信给克洛维斯，本质上不是将克洛维斯欢呼为国王，而是将其誉为罗马高卢东北部省份的新总督。我们保留了他写给克洛维斯的信。信中说道，你对人们的恩泽必须纯洁而诚实，你必须尊敬你的主教，并且必须时刻听从他们的建议。这完全是他写给罗马总督时的口吻。嗯，信中说，你就像你的祖先一直做的那样开始，这并不奇怪。是的。
So there's no sense there of like, this is a huge rupture. Absolute continuity. This is just as things always are. You're the legitimate authority. You've moved in, you've taken power. Great. Everything continues as it always has. Yes. Now there is, of course, a complication here, which is that Clovis, like his forefathers,
所以并没有任何“这是一次巨大断裂”的感觉。绝对的连续性。这只是一切如常。你是合法的权威。你搬了进来，你夺取了权力。很好。一切都像以前一样继续。是的。现在，当然这里有一个复杂的情况，那就是克洛维斯和他的祖先一样，
he's not a Christian. He worships the Roman gods. And that is unlike the other barbarian kings who've seized power in Gaul, who have adopted Christianity, but tellingly a heretical form of Christianity. Arianism, right? Yeah. So God the Son, so Christ is not held to be of one essence with God the Father. He's subordinate to God the Father. And that enables them to kind of buy into the fabric of Christian civilisation but to be a part and, as they see it, superior to their Roman subjects. What will Clovis do? Because the more he advances southwards into Gaul. So in a way, the more pressing it is that he arrives
他不是基督徒。他崇拜罗马诸神。这与那些夺取了高卢权力、已经皈依基督教的蛮族国王不同，但颇具意味的是，他们皈依的是一种异端形式的基督教。阿里乌斯派（Arianism），对吧？是的。因此，上帝之子——也就是基督——不被认为与圣父上帝具有同一本质。他从属于圣父上帝。这使得他们能够融入基督教文明的体制中，但又能保持独立，并且在他们看来，要优于他们的罗马子民。克洛维斯会怎么做呢？因为随着他越发向南深入高卢，从某种意义上说，他越迫切需要
at an accommodation with the Christian elites of Roman Gaul. And you can see him over the course of his life kind of doing this in a gingerly way, like someone kind of inching his way into a very cold swimming pool. So he has married a Burgundian princess called Clotilda, who unlike Battle of Tolbiac, where son survives and Clovis is happy for that son to be baptised. And then comes the decisive moment according to tradition at the Battle of Tolbiac where he defeats the Alemannian. People remember that this is the moment where he thinks he's going to lose and he raises a vow and the vow is to the Christian God and Clovis says, if you allow me to win this battle I will turn to you, I will convert.' And he wins the battle and
与罗马高卢的基督教精英达成某种妥协。你可以看到他在自己的一生中小心翼翼地这样做，就像一个人试探着走进一个非常冰冷的水池一样。所以他娶了一位名叫克洛蒂尔达（Clotilda）的勃艮第公主，与托尔比亚克战役不同的是，他们的儿子活了下来，克洛维斯也很高兴让那个儿子受洗。然后，根据传统，在托尔比亚克战役中迎来了决定性的时刻，他击败了阿勒曼尼人。人们记得，这就是他以为自己要输并许下誓言的时刻，这个誓言是对基督教上帝许下的，克洛维斯说：“如果你让我赢得这场战役，我将转向你，我将皈依。”他赢得了战役，并且
he is true to his vow and not just Clovis but 3,000 of his followers it is said and we get that report from the great historian of 6th century Gaul, a guy called Gregory of Tor who's the bishop, writes this incredible history and we'll be drawing on it a lot in our next episode but Gregory does also write about Clovis and he reports that Clovis and his 3,000 followers are baptized on Christmas day by Remedius, this holy bishop who can raise the dead back to life in Raus and Gregory writes, like some new Constantine Clovis stepped forward to the baptismal pool ready to wash away the sores of his old leprosy and to be cleansed in flowing water from the sordid stains which he had borne so long. And this Dominic of course is why
他兑现了自己的誓言，不仅是克洛维斯，据说还有他的3000名追随者——我们是从6世纪高卢的伟大历史学家图尔的格里高利（Gregory of Tours）那里得知这一报道的，他是一名主教，写下了这部不可思议的历史，我们将在下一集中大量引用它——但格里高利确实也写到了克洛维斯，他记录说，克洛维斯和他的3000名追随者在圣诞节那天由雷米迪乌斯（这位能让死者复活的神圣主教）在兰斯（Reims）受洗，格里高利写道：“克洛维斯宛如一个新的君士坦丁，步入洗礼池，准备洗去他旧麻风病的疮痂，并在流动的清水中洗净他长期忍受的肮脏污渍。”当然，多米尼克，这就是为什么
we've been doing this series on the French Revolution. That's why Louis XVI was crowned and anointed in Reus. And it's actually why Louis is called Louis because Louis is a variant of Clovis. Just on Clovis' conversion, an alternative explanation for why he does it is not just because he thinks God has given him victory at Tobias, but it's also, I might not write in thinking that adopting Christianity is becoming increasingly high status. Yes, absolutely. It's a way of assimilating himself into the elite now that he's beaten his enemies, got the power, he's upgrading to a more high class religion that will ensure
我们一直在做关于法国大革命这个系列的原因。这就是为什么路易十六在兰斯加冕并接受涂油礼。这也是为什么路易会被命名为路易，因为路易（Louis）是克洛维斯（Clovis）的一个变体。单就克洛维斯的皈依而言，对他为什么这么做的另一种解释不仅是因为他认为上帝在托尔比亚克赋予了他胜利，还因为——我这样想可能没错——皈依基督教正变得越来越具有崇高的地位。是的，绝对是的。这是他在击败敌人、掌握权力后，将自己同化入精英阶层的一种方式，他正在升级到一个更高档次的宗教，这将确保
his acceptance by the other provincial power brokers, right? I don't think they're mutually exclusive. No. You can feel that your own needs and those of God are compatible if you are the chosen one of God. So often the way. But of course the key thing is that the form of Christianity that Clovis has converted to, unlike that of the Visigothic or Burgundian or Alemannic kings, it is an Arianism. It's the orthodox form of Christianity, the Roman form of Christianity. And this means that Clovis can be acknowledged not just by his rival barbarian compadres but by the Roman emperor who still prevails and presides over
他被其他行省的权力掮客所接受，对吧？我不认为这二者是互不排斥的。不。如果你是上帝的选民，你会觉得你自己的需求和上帝的需求是相容的。通常都是这样。但当然，关键在于，克洛维斯皈依的基督教形式，与西哥特、勃艮第或阿勒曼尼国王的基督教不同，它不是阿里乌斯派。它是正统形式的基督教，也就是罗马形式的基督教。这意味着克洛维斯不仅能得到他那些蛮族竞争对手同僚的承认，还能得到仍在君士坦丁堡统治和主导
a Roman empire in Constantinople. And so the key indicator of this comes in 508 after he's captured Toulouse, the capital of the Gothic kingdom, and he's heading southwards tellingly to tour the shrine of Saint Martin and on his way he's met by emissaries of the Roman Emperor Anastasius who presents him with this official document that honours him and recognises him as a Consul of the Roman people. So this is official recognition from the new Rome and this is brilliant for Clovis because you know he's this barbarian war, but he's also now a Roman consul. And so he then heads to the shrine of St. Martin, this unbelievably potent saint of Roman Gaul. And he goes into the shrine and Gregory of Tor writes, he stood there clad in a purple
罗马帝国的罗马皇帝的承认。这一切的关键标志出现在508年，在他攻陷哥特王国首都图卢兹之后，他向南进发，意味深长地去巡视圣马丁圣地，在路上，他遇到了罗马皇帝阿纳斯塔修斯（Anastasius）的使节，使节向他呈递了一份官方文件，对维系其荣誉并承认他为罗马人民的执政官（Consul）。这是来自新罗马的官方认可，这对于克洛维斯来说太棒了，因为你知道，他是一个蛮族军阀，但现在他也是一个罗马执政官。于是他接着前往圣马丁圣地，这是罗马高卢具有不可思议强大力量的圣徒。他走进圣殿，图尔的格里高利写道：“他站在那里，身穿紫色
tunic and the cloak of a Roman general, and he crowned himself with a diadem. So again, I mean, very much as Napoleon in due course will do, so kind of providing a role model. And it's a sumptuous setting. So by this point, you've got a great complex of churches and courtyards and towers that have been built around the tomb of St. Martin and over the tomb itself, there's this glittering gilded dome. Clovis comes out from the shrine and he scatters gold and silver coins as he rides through the streets to the cathedral where
束腰外衣和罗马将军的斗篷，头戴皇冠。”同样，这非常类似于日后拿破仑所做的事，堪称提供了一个榜样。这是一个极其奢华的场景。到这个时候，圣马丁的墓穴周围已经建立起了一组宏伟的教堂、庭院和塔楼，而在墓穴本身上方，则是一个闪闪发光的镀金圆顶。克洛维斯从圣殿走出来，一边骑马穿过街道前往大教堂，一边沿途撒下金银硬币，在那里
he's welcomed by the bishop and Gregory writes, from that day onwards he was hailed as Consul or Augustus. And it's such a genius move. I'll read you what Patrick Geary, who's one of the great historians of this whole process of how Gaul becomes France. Now no cult barrier separated the army from the indigenous inhabitants of Gaul. The peasants, artisans and most importantly the Gallo-Roman aristocracy and its leaders the bishops for whom religion was an essential element of their identity. Christianisation made possible not only the close cooperation between Gallo-Romans and Franks, but a real amalgamation of the two peoples, a process well underway at all levels by the sixth century. So a massively significant manoeuvre on the
他受到了主教的欢迎，格里高利写道：“从那一天起，他被欢呼为执政官或奥古斯都。”这是一个如此天才的举动。我给你们读一段帕特里克·吉里（Patrick Geary）的话，他是高卢如何变成法兰克这一整个进程的伟大历史学家之一：“现在，没有任何文化障碍将军队与高卢的本土居民隔离开来。农民、工匠，以及最最重要的——高卢-罗马贵族及其领袖主教们（对他们而言，宗教是其身份认同的重要组成部分），基督教化不仅使高卢-罗马人和法兰克人之间的紧密合作成为可能，还促成了两者的真正融合，到了六世纪，这一进程已经在各个层面上如火如荼地展开。”所以这是一个具有划时代意义的举动
part of Clovis with kind of epical consequences. But here's the thing, Clovis is not just turning himself into another Roman because the fact that he has gone to the shrine of Saint Martin, who is this guy who left the Roman army, who was an outsider, whose whole persona was based on his kind of monasticism, his rejection of wealth and all that kind of thing, who is somebody who's not an elite person, that's something new isn't it? That he is identifying himself with somebody who's very much on the fringe, on the periphery, and therefore creating a new kind of identity, a new kind of power base for himself. Yeah. And Martin is this guy who can perform incredible miracles, and that has given him
克洛维斯的这一举动带来了具有划时代意义的结果。但关键在于，克洛维斯并不仅仅是将自己变成又一个罗马人，因为事实上他去了圣马丁的圣殿——这个曾离开罗马军队、是个局外人、其整个人设都建立在隐修主义、拒绝财富以及诸如此类基础之上的家伙，一个并非精英阶层的人——这难道不是某种新鲜事物吗？他将自己认同为一个非常处于边缘、处于外围的人，从而为自己创造了一种新的身份、一个新的权力基础。是的。马丁就是那个能够显现不可思议神迹的人，这赋予了他
power. And power is kind of equivalent to lordship. And it's a lordship that stands outside the traditional power structures of the Gallo-Roman elite. And so it's brilliant for Clovis to identify himself with that. He can be Christian, he can be completely orthodox, it's all very Roman, but at the same time, it's outside the frameworks of snobbery and prestige of that kind of class of bishops who essentially remain the arbiters of power in all the various cities of Roman Gaul but Clovis by identifying himself with Saint Martin is kind of putting himself over and above them. It's an absolutely brilliant move and it's reflective of his absolute
权力。而权力在某种程度上等同于统治权。这种统治权超出了高卢-罗马精英阶层的传统权力结构。因此，克洛维斯将自己与此联系起来实在是太妙了。他可以是基督徒，他可以完全正统，这一切都非常罗马化，但与此同时，它又超出了罗马高卢各个城市中基本上仍然是权力仲裁者的那类主教们的势利与声望框架，而克洛维斯通过将自己与圣马丁联系起来，实际上是将自己置于他们之上。这是一个绝对绝妙的举动，它反映了他坚决
determination to acknowledge no rivals let alone any equals. He is absolutely the superior and just as adopting Saint Martin enables him to put the bishops of Roman Gaul in the shade, so also does he spend the last years of his life, so in the wake of his conversion, basically going around like a kind of mafia boss and exterminating all the other Frankish chieftains. And again, Gregory of Tours has a very funny passage about this. So he describes Clovis one day when he had called a general assembly of his subjects. He is said to have made the following remark
不承认任何对手、更不用说任何平庸之辈的决心。他绝对是高高在上的。正如采用圣马丁使他能够让罗马高卢的主教们黯然失色一样，他在生命的最后几年里——也就是在他皈依之后——基本上就像一个黑帮老大一样四处奔走，将其他所有的法兰克酋长赶尽杀绝。同样，图尔的格里高利对此有一段非常有趣的记述。他描述了克洛维斯有一天召集他的子民召开全体大会时的情景。据说他发表了以下言论
about the relatives whom he had destroyed, so all the other Frankish chieftains. How sad a thing it is, he said, that I live among strangers like some solitary pilgrim and that I have none of my own relations left to help me when disaster threatens. But he said this not because he grieved for their deaths, Gregor Taurides, but because in his cunning way he hoped to find some relatives still in the land of the living whom he could kill. He's a ruthless man. He is. But you know, ruthlessness pays dividends in the troubled circumstances of the early
关于他所消灭的亲属，也就是所有其他的法兰克酋长。他说：“我生活在陌生人中间，就像一个孤独的朝圣者，当我遭遇灾难时，身边连一个可以帮我的亲人都没有，这是一件多么可悲的事情啊。”图尔的格里高利写道，他说这话并不是因为他为他们的死感到悲伤，而是因为他出于自己狡猾的心思，希望能在这世上找到某个还能活着的亲属，然后把他也杀掉。他是一个冷酷无情的人。他的确是。但你知道，在动荡不安的早期的
sixth century. Right. By 511 when he dies, he gets buried in Paris. So he's the first Frankish king to be buried in Paris. He has established the most formidable kingdom in what had been the Western Roman Empire. And his dynasty, the Merovingians, like Clovis, they will rule both as the sacred, long-haired descendants of a sea monster,
六世纪，冷酷无情是有回报的。没错。到511年他去世时，他被安葬在巴黎。因此他是第一位被安葬在巴黎的法兰克国王。他在曾经的西罗马帝国领土上建立起了最强大的王国。他的王朝——墨洛温王朝，将同克洛维斯一样，既作为海怪的神圣长毛后裔来统治，
but also as the descendants of an Augustus, of a Roman consul. And of course they have in Saint Martin this patron of unbelievable potency. And even the Merovingian kings who follow Clovis will be a bit intimidated by Saint Martin so they actually they tend to avoid his tomb because they're nervous of him. They don't want their own charisma to be blotted out by the much greater charisma of the saint and in due course they obtain that cloak Dominic which Saint Martin had cut in half and given to the beggar and it becomes the kind of the great totem of Merovingian power, the badge of Frankish greatness and they set up a special class of
同时也作为奥古斯都、罗马执政官的后裔来统治。当然，他们还有圣马丁这个拥有不可思议强大力量的守护神。甚至克洛维斯之后的墨洛温国王们也对圣马丁感到有些敬畏，所以他们实际上往往会避开他的陵墓，因为他们对圣马丁感到紧张。他们不希望自己的个人威望（charisma）被圣徒更为巨大的威望所掩盖。不久之后，他们得到了那件斗篷，多米尼克——圣马丁曾将它切成两半并施舍给乞丐的那件斗篷，它成为了墨洛温权力的大图腾、法兰克伟大的象征，他们设立了一个特殊的阶层
priest to look after this cloak, capella in Latin and these priests are called the capellani or chaplains and this cloak, this capella as it's called in Latin, comes to be guarded by a special class of priest who are called the capellani or chaplains. This is in due course where we get the word chapel from and these capellani, these chaplains will follow it when the Merovingian king rides into war and it bears stunning witness to the way in which Roman military power and Christian sacral power have been fused by this barbarian king to become a source of unbelievable potency. And it's that fusion of the Roman, the Christian, the barbarian that will typify the emergence of the Frankish kingdom in the sixth century. Okay, so it begins. Now the one thing we didn't talk
由祭司来照看这件斗篷（拉丁语中称作 capella），这些祭司被称为 capellani 或随军牧师。这件斗篷，即拉丁语中所称的 capella，后来由一个特殊的祭司阶层看守，他们被称为 capellani 或随军牧师。这正是我们后来获得“小教堂”（chapel）这个词的来源，当墨洛温国王骑马出征时，这些 capellani（随军牧师）会随行相伴，这有力地见证了罗马军事力量与基督教神圣力量如何被这位蛮族国王融合在一起，并成为一股不可思议的强大力量之源。正是罗马、基督教和蛮族的这种融合，将成为六世纪法兰克王国崛起典型特征。好了，故事开始了。现在，我们在今天的节目中没有谈论的一件事
about in today's episode, it had sea monsters, it had magic cloaks, it had the works, but it didn't have many women. But the great news is that in the next episode we will be exploring the warrior queens of the Franks and their mad rivalries. It's unbelievable story. There will be all kinds of extremely, extremely bad behaviour. So that's a lot to look forward to. If you remember the Rest is History club, you can actually hear that episode right away. And by the way, you can sign up at therestorshistory.com. If you're not, however, you will have to wait until Thursday for the blood feud between Queen Fredegund and her great rival Queen Brunhilde. So we'll be back on Thursday with that story or indeed right away if you remember The Restors History Club and on that bombshell, merci et au revoir. Goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是，它有海怪，有魔法斗篷，什么都有，但没有多少女性。不过好消息是，在下一集中，我们将探索法兰克人的女战士女王以及她们之间疯狂的明争暗斗。这是一个令人难以置信的故事。其中会有各种各样极其极其糟糕的行为。所以有很多内容值得期待。如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”（Rest is History Club）的会员，你实际上可以立即收听那一集。顺便说一句，你可以在 therestorshistory.com 注册。如果不是的话，你将不得不等到周 Thursday 才能听到弗雷德贡德女王（Queen Fredegund）与她的死敌布伦希尔德女王（Queen Brunhilde）之间的血亲复仇故事。所以我们周四会带着这个故事回归，或者如果你是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的会员，你可以马上收听。伴随着这个重磅消息，谢谢大家，再见。再见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。